>>> BREAKING NEWS, THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE SAYS THE PANEL IS
SENDING OUT SUBPOENAS AS EARLY
AS THIS WEEK, AS LAWMAKERS PRESS
TOP TRUMP ALLIES TO COOPERATE
WITH THEIR INVESTIGATION.
PAULA REID IS ON THE STORY FOR
US TONIGHT.
THIS POTENTIALLY COULD BE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT IN THE
JANUARY 6th PROBE.
>> MORE SUBPOENAS, ABSOLUTELY A
VERY SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT.
NOW, REPRESENTATIVE BENNIE
THOMPSON WHO CHAIRS THE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6th TELLS CNN THAT THE COMMITTEE
COULD BE SENDING OUT MORE
SUBPOENAS THIS WEEK, THOUGH HE
WOULDN'T SPECIFY WHO WOULD BE IN
THIS NEXT GROUP, HE DID SAY IT
WOULD LIKELY BE A BROADER GROUP
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE AND POTENTIALLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH CRIMES ASSOCIATED
WITH JANUARY 6th.
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE'S
QUEST TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AS PART
OF ITS INVESTIGATION INTO THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION MAY
SOON BE COMING TO A HEAD.
TRUMP FACES A LOOMING DEADLINE
FOR EXERTING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
TO BLOCK SUBPOENAS FOR FOUR OF
HIS CLOSEST ALLIES AND OTHER
REQUESTS FOR DOCUMENTS.
>> A BIAS, HIT JOB THAT IS
WASTING EVERYBODY'S TIME.
>> COMMITTEE MEMBER, SLOF LOFGR
>> WE ARE TAKING CIVIL ACTION
AND CRIMINAL ACTION.
>> LAWMAKERS ARE TAKING
TESTIMONY FROM THE DEFENDANTS
WHO HAVE BEEN CHARGED IN THE
JANUARY 6th RIOT TO PROVIDE AN
ACCOUNT OF WHY THEY TRAVELED TO
WASHINGTON THAT DAY TO JOIN THE
MOB.
THIS COMES AS FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP CONTINUES HIS BASELESS
ATTACKS ON THE AMERICAN
ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
>> THEY ATTACKED AND CHEATED ON
OUR ELECTIONS.
>> Reporter: HE LASHED OUT AT
REPUBLICAN LEADERS IN GEORGIA
WHO WOULD NOT HELP HIM TO
UNDERMINE CONFIDENCE IN THE
ELECTION.
GOING SO FAR AS TO SUGGEST THE
STATE WOULD BE BETTER OFF WITH
DEMOCRAT STACEY ABRAMS.
>> OF COURSE HAVING HER MIGHT BE
BETTER THAN HAVING YOUR EXISTING
GOVERNOR.
MIGHT VERY WELL BE BETTER.
>> AND EVEN SEEMED TO CONFESS TO
PRESSURING GEORGIA'S GOVERNOR TO
HELP HIM OVERTURN THE STATE'S
RESULTS.
>> I SAID, BRIAN, LISTEN, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE A BIG ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROBLEM IN GEORGIA.
I HOPE YOU CAN HELP US OUT AND
CALL A SPECIAL ELECTION.
>> Reporter: THEN OUTRIGHT LIED
ABOUT THE RECENT SHAM REVIEW IN
ARIZONA, CLAIMING HE WON.
>> WE WON ON THE ARIZONA
FORENSIC AUDIT YESTERDAY AT A
LEVEL THAT YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
>> Reporter: WHEN FIN FACT, THE
PARTISAN EXERCISE CONDUCT BID
CYBER NINJAS, A FLORIDA BASED
COMPANY NOT EXPERIENCED IN
AUDITING FOUND 99 MORE VOTES FOR
JOE BIDEN, AND 261 FEWER VOTES
FOR TRUMP.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH 60 MINUTES,
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTATIVE LIZ
CHENEY SAID OTHER REPUBLICANS
PRIVATELY TELL HER THEY AGREE
WITH HER CRITICISM OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BUT WON'T SAY ANYTHING
IN PUBLIC.
>> IF REPUBLICAN LEADERS DON'T
STAND UP AND CONDEMN WHAT
HAPPENED, THEN THE VOICES IN THE
PARTY THAT ARE SO DANGEROUS WILL
ONLY GET LOUDER AND STRONGER!
AND SHE SINGLED OUT HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
>> WHAT HE'S DONE IS EMBRACED
DONALD TRUMP, AND IF I WERE
DOING WHAT HE'S DOING, I WOULD
BE DEEPLY ASHAMED OF MYSELF.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU EXPLAIN
THAT TO YOUR CHILDREN.
>> Reporter: SHE WAS CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, SPECIFICALLY OF
HIS POLICIES IN AFGHANISTAN AND
HIS HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY.
BUT SAID THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE A BETTER OPTION THAN
TRUMP.
>> THE ALTERNATIVE CANNOT BE A
MAN WHO DOESN'T BELIEVE IN THE
RULE OF LAW, AND WHO VIOLATED
HIS OATH OF OFFICE.
>> Reporter: CHENEY IS ONE OF
TWO REPUBLICANS ON THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE WHICH HAS SENT
SUBPOENAS TO TRUMP ADVISERS THEY
BELIEVE MIGHT RESIST COOPERATING
IN THE PROBE.
IF THOSE TRUMP LOYALISTS REFUSE
TO HAND OVER DOCUMENTS DUE NEXT
WEEK OR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRIES TO EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, THAT COULD SET OFF A
LENGTHY COURT BATTLE.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, PAULA REID
REPORTING FOR US.
LET'S GET MORE INSIGHT FROM CNN
POLITICAL ANALYST, MAGGIE
HABERMAN, THE WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
SHE CAN RING ALL THE ALARM
BELLS, BUT THE FACT IS THE
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS
STILL SAY THEY THINK THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
HOW MUCH WEIGHT DOES HER VOICE
CARRY IN ALL OF THIS?
>> LOOK, I THINK, WOLF, HER
VOICE IS MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT,
FRANKLY, AMONG PEOPLE LIKE US
THAN IT IS AMONG GRASS ROOTS
REPUBLICANS, AND AMONG SOME
SENIOR REPUBLICANS, SOME
INDEPENDENT, SHE IS A
SIGNIFICANT VOICE, BUT IT DOES
NOT CARRY THE SAME SWAY AS
DONALD TRUMP'S VOICE DOES WITH
THIS GROUP OF VOTERS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
DETER HER FROM SAYING WHAT SHE'S
SAYING, AND I THINK THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE DEEPLY
OPPOSED TO FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND WHO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD, BUT
AT THE MOMENT, THE PARTY'S BASE
IS WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
CONTRARY TO PREDICTIONS THAT
THAT WAS GOING TO CHANGE WHEN HE
LEFT OFFICE, WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT.
IF ANYTHING, WE HAVE SEEN THE
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE,
YOU KNOW, BOUGHT HIS FALSEHOODS
ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION HAVE
ALSO GROWN.
>> REPRESENTATIVE CHENEY TALKS
TO COLLEAGUES WHO AGREE WITH
HER.
AMONG REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
WHO BACKED TRUMP, HOW MANY ARE
TRUE BELIEVERS, AND HOW MANY ARE
JUST DOING IT FOR POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY.
>> IT'S SOME COMBINATION, MOST
POLITICIANS ARE INTERESTED THIS
THEIR OWN POLITICAL FUTURE,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEY SAY, AND
THAT IS ACROSS THE BOARD.
WHAT IS TRUE ABOUT A LOT OF
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS AND OR AT
LEAST SOME AT THIS POINT, I
WOULDN'T SAY A LOT BUT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS A LOT OF
THEM LIKE HIM.
A LOT OF THEM FILL AN AFFINITY
TOWARD HIM, FEEL BONDED TO HIM
IN WAYS THAT YOU DON'T ALWAYS
SEE WITH POLITICAL LEADERS AND
OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS.
IT'S PART OF WHY HE WAS ABLE TO
SURVIVE THE FIRST IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S WHY HE ON JANUARY 6th HAD
SO MANY REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
WILLING TO NOT VOTE TO CERTIFY A
SECURE ELECTION, AND ITS
OUTCOME.
AND SO THERE IS THIS BALANCING
ACT, BUT WHAT THE CONGRESSWOMAN
SAYS ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
LAWMAKERS WHO ALSO RESENT HIM,
WHO FEEL AS IF HE HAS HIS BOOT
ON THEIR NECKS, THAT'S REAL TOO.
>> CERTAINLY IS.
I KNOW, MAGGIE, YOU HAVE
EXPLAINED THAT TRUMP OPERATES IN
TEN-MIN INCREMENTS, IS THAT
STILL THE CASE OR IS THERE A
LONG-TERM STRATEGY AT WORK AS HE
CONTINUES TO QUESTION THE
RESULTS OF THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION?
>> HE HAS NOT OPERATED ON
LONG-TERM STRATEGY AS LONG AS HE
HAS BEEN IN ADULTHOOD.
IT HAS NOT CHANGED SINCE HE LEFT
OFFICE.
LOOK, THERE'S A DIVISION OF
OPINION ON WHETHER HE IS GOING
TO RUN FOR OFFICE AGAIN.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO THINK HE IS
DEFINITELY DOING IT.
GOING TO ACT AS IF HE IS, AND
ULTIMATELY NOT DO IT BECAUSE
HE'S THAT FORMULATION IS HE'S
WORRIED ABOUT LOSING A SECOND
TIMEMENT
TIME.
A GENERAL ELECTION WOULD BE HARD
FOR HIM.
THAT IS NOT HOW HE PROJECTED
THESE THINGS OUT.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS ANY
DIFFERENT.
I THINK AT THE MOMENT HIS
BUSINESS IS MAKING MONEY IN
POLITICS, AND TALKING ABOUT
RUNNING IS HOW YOU DO THAT.
HOWEVER, THAT CAN THEN TRIGGER
ACTUALLY RUNNING.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT'S SO
WORRISOME, MAGGIE IS THAT THE
THREATS POSED BY TRUMP AND THOSE
WHO BELIEVE HIS LIES ABOUT THE
ELECTION ARE NOT A THINK OF THE
PAST.
THE ONGOING ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES IS
VERY REAL AND VERY DANGEROUS,
ISN'T IT?
>> IT'S VERY REAL, WOLF, AND I
THINK THAT WHAT THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SAY, NOBODY SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT DONALD TRUMP
ARE SAYING OR MISSING IS ONE OF
HIS ABILITIES IS TO GET OTHER
PEOPLE TO DO THINGS IN HIS NAME
AND FOR HIM OFTEN SO THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE HIS FINGER PRINTS.
WHAT'S BEEN SO STRIKING IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS IS HIM
TALKING ABOUT HIS CALL TO BRIAN
KEMP AND THE PRESSURE THAT HE
WAS EXERTING ON BRIAN KEMP
BECAUSE HE TRIES TO HAVE A
BUFFER AND DISTANCE.
IT'S NOT AS IF HE'S OPERATING IN
A VACUUM.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL DO
THINGS IN SUPPORT OF HIM AND IN
HIS NAME, AND YOU'RE SEE